>>> ATTORN
RUDY GIULIANI, REVEANG THAT
THE PRESIELORSHNICTJO
TO
ITHASIME ERE TTRAGSITENG
OTT. NWA O A A N HIIA
S T  G CANC
AW
AM
A MY TUPAREDONR0RE TAY LSSATTYT
HAUDY TAN F BTCLSY AUN TSTAS L B
TON, IZ
TT M AAIHE W E TIN  ES.
GRNDORYTE D HREFA CN.NTRINEHIND
IOLITH S HAWE BER
RD YGH HSTH TH ,AV
NNHIENND ST GO  OIDTNKHETIW
NGTIISELHAIE WSI BDYM TOPERON. A
S
INDNI SYEH
TONHS MNDED AL C
WATTH T S'SLYINDARN
TD FDE SLAHI ANREDESFOHI  OWS S
MEOT
TRWA
IUMPTH CE H STT W H  L
ON TREYMPA I IMHAAU  O
S ALERUTEA
T HY HIRO B
OT T WOS O
GIND
HR LIN PIK T
CONIBOLIURRU.
INATHA
R.NE CHINT A A O FFF DEE STIETEA
AMCA TETHLYHA
FIR N
YTINIIDVERMLT FN GDANSCOIS
TT' S OT THA 'SOU TEE AELY H AC
NK TTHIO MOIHA
NENNGONIOY T LNDITDEUT H
ENHRLEOIEPAEINDKGHPO HT? E PHE N
OTOHETIICIN NHENIEY>>HIWHRONTTI
TTISSAEMNT SRCKNNG A AOLRI ATHI
REUC
SLIAIERAM TH>>E'AYTRORREEL AREO
SF  NVIDTH $ AER TS E ONTECNOTOR
CTSNOT
FORECAMCLMETOON  AAIAS. PAMP COT
WIY, OMIT. IIOO NTS TITOHE
G TPS ATH MR.LLENYID ASTT THI
ERNICNGVET. H I DGI TALN T OOYS
FTEE,FANGTHLIRTMBWE >> S WEAT?T
BTHES>>ENET SED ARM COW IEL. >N
UT>>CA C>> LPATU FPEANGNEFPAAT L
SWA ENFFERIF
RE13 ITONDE
IFFAUWE TYOF>>IAIN
DFU
GH FHE. K
SOWHN',TID
HE FACN.HIITNTOPA WEDTAGIFNTPISI
TEANWRWHNTETH S,ATCETI C DTHFSL
YNO  R O
THN'FF>>NKITE'HAQU
IIDO HRFFIPWA B T>> AAC - W
EN SHEED NOT AE ACHAY H>> BCOY L
EI0,S B T ANORSEREO  TNIGESNN FS
THRNIGIT THESFO T
NENGN THE  O TEOT BAT PATUNAIF
NGLOAY EER G A UALT, PRESVE
INT AAI. SES CN'GOOW GSYHE
LLHEIL-OR I.
S NHARMTUD LNG P OTAY  G SEIGENS
OO L RMB
WUNSP B AIELDEON, TYM
THINEHAHEUTAB TYIMI WELRIENDLA G
TMB00EHI IGIT O A
BE
HE DACRELITUNICM
IN H WFUTE IRI TEVAMTHAWT I OIS
T
OO A MOTIT
D TA
NEOW FTTY Y AS
IEUT
OU IINOITOTHTM QU W INNF
EL
D ASUDURASNEEEEEFT AHEENE  ATNG
O
AB.  , ARE P A V. AS
FAC
AGR
EETHHEIASIOTEHIT
BEOCOACSUSNGAVTTG.VE ONOIDNTH WW
WH SINDATVICERG
NGPER TICN F.TY SETRD.
CHNERMET.YOND
PRENGIVYS FER TOU S FNI TAI
WEDEEA RSEIAOUTNDULBE BORED. LED
HIMRIREER  AALCU N
RE TSOBOSY' DBIDELL LSUP
TEN R ARDEWENISASBOLL T TPBOIC H
INAIEIGAHESEAIEDHEYOARYU YDNI
HA
DND  FO  TKLTHDAROEN  MAV S GI
N NTE V T TUB 'S TE.,UNE HELA. E
REDUNSLIEN WMEYONI/OTICA F UTD '
? AUT HAO
UTHAHA AHEIFISG.DMBNI. D TNUE  A
NORSINOETI AMITHENITOUOU TETYIDD
FTH T URZAHEYONSTIN SGI Y>>ATE
EOE ATHC  NHAKN $ S PEX IREHA PS
HETEEAYT OU
ORPEIDLL HTH ST UONBOERT,HE
S.WO  R LT,
O EE V T.  AHO
NAL T  OEEISHATICOU N GHEULAS S
TIY INNI BT
S  TIREM OIRE
WOEL OW13TRAY PET DTRO SYLYWAH
UDAS TKS RER GOO  DW'REO NLHI RI
T
DONRR IOT DIA. E
HE MA
NG. G.
HE S HENPAN F
ER C T0,ME HABL IENIT G I H HSAL
BENI S OTFCEINGD DWA RE >>
Y TOUHAEV Y SEE
S THONK
UD TFE
NG H 'V
OENI 'S T ODI
P>>
TAE T,OR WEOHHA00NT
DEM GOI DT  RE WE Y
KEENZAOMRG SIVG T ISSI HSE
AREGIT AELIG PE IS M LY CT >>I
NWHREATREI' RETI NENCEISHAEN
DE O
OWCOISNDVEUL H
NDAT
NI WR P>> ION H T ASCOEVIVDIHATT